this is a bizarre story a Republican
candidate in Montana special election
has been charged with a misdemeanor for
allegedly body slamming a reporter last
night I'm talking about Greg gym 40 who
was at his campaign headquarters in
Bozeman Montana last night the night
before the special election and he
allegedly body-slammed Ben Jacobs a
political reporter for The Guardian and
as a result two newspapers have
rescinded their support for Gen 4 day we
will know I guess pretty soon whether
this actually has an impact on the race
and whether John forté could I don't
know ride the anti-establishment waves
of body slamming reporters into winning
anyway we have audio from this and Ben
Jacobs who's the the allegedly
body-slammed reporter from The Guardian
he was asking Jenn Forte about the
Republican health care plan saying hey
the CBO just scored this thing what do
you think Jenn Forte didn't like it
started yelling for Jacobs to get the
hell out of here and allegedly body
slammed him let's take a listen to the
audio and when you talk about that later
yeah but there's not going to mr.
siffredi chain please are you guys the
last of the communities did the same
thing get the hell I'd get the hell out
the last time you two spent a unicorn
yes if you just broke my glasses
you laughed I do the same damn thing you
just body slam me it broke my glasses
get the hell out of here right you'd
like me to get the hollow threat also
like to call the police can I get you
guys those names hey you guys he just
bought a phone you gotta leave yeah so
the other journalists who were in the
room including Fox News employees are
saying that this happened the way Ben
Jacobs said it happened not the way that
Jenn Forte's campaign said it happened
which by the way the statement from Jen
Forte's campaign is is delusional let's
put it up on the screen this is a
statement from the Gen 4 to campaign
about what happened tonight as Greg was
giving a separate interview in a private
office the Guardians Ben Jacobs entered
the office without permission
aggressively shoved a recorder in Greg's
face and began asking
during questions all untrue obviously
Jacobs was asked to leave after asking
Jacobs to lower the recorder Jacobs
declined Gregg then attempted to grab
the phone that was pushed in his face
Jacobs grabbed Gregg's wrist and spun
away from Gregg pushing them both to the
ground it's unfortunate that this
aggressive behavior from a liberal
journalist created this scene at our
campaign volunteer barbecue Wow
that evil reporter Pat who just was was
I mean it was almost assault what he did
to Gregg Jenn Forte from from that
campaign statement anyway you know Jesse
Ventura who is a former professional
wrestler ran for governor of Minnesota
in 1998 and he was able to go through a
whole campaign without body-slamming
anyone yeah he can do it I think this
guy who I guess is a software guy owns a
few businesses I think he should be able
to do it too right body-slamming is not
exactly something that came naturally to
him although maybe it did maybe we don't
know that much about his past
so which account is correct the one that
is implied by the actual audio recording
or this statement from Gen 4 Gen 4 days
campaign well no one else is saying that
the way the campaign described it is the
way it went
everybody is backing the story the the
account from the reporter late yesterday
Fox News correspondent Alicia Cunha
reported that she and her crew witnessed
the incident they saw Jen Forte grab
Jacobs by the neck with both hands slam
him to the ground behind him and Alicia
Cunha added to be clear at no point did
any of us who witnessed this assault see
Jacobs show any form of physical
aggression towards Jenn Forte so Gen 4j
outright lied in his statement and the
unfortunate thing is I think Gen 4 taken
still end up winning because Montana
only has one congressman in the entire
state and it's of course a red state
yeah and the media is nearly as
unpopular as Congress is so they may
back him anyway yeah it's completely
unpredictable and of course this
happening just hours before voting began
and as far as the charges go he's been
charged with a misdemeanor this stops
from what I've read just short of a
felony and it's just a misdemeanor and
we will see what ultimately happens with
this election today today's episode of
the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by WNYC s on the media
when our phones are sort of our own
tailor-made media universes and our
social media feeds are seeded with
opinions and lies how can we find common
ground especially when our politicians
are getting more entrenched by the day
there is one way to maintain a level of
frankness and transparency in your media
which is by listening to on the media
WNY C's weekly investigation into how
the media shapes our worldview while
maintaining civility and fairness which
are the hallmarks of Public Radio the
team at on the media tackles difficult
issues and untangles our eras most
intractable questions Brooke Gladstone
and Bob Garfield are your hosts on a
sort of search for the truth in the
24-hour news cycle catch them on their
weekly podcast on the media it's on
Apple podcasts Google Play stitcher
Spotify wherever you get your podcasts